drew bearmore got a long list of
surprises during his special birthday
edition of the drew barrymore show yeah
and drew couldn't help but break down
any tears when her heroes the go-go's
surprised her on zoom take a look we'll
see you back here tomorrow
bye okay it says i'm supposed to read
the prompter and we have another
surprise it's a surprise guest i have no
idea who it is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
oh my god
belinda carlisle jane wiedland gina
shock charlotte kathy and kathy
valentine the go-go's everybody
oh my gosh
the last time we saw each other was that
the rock and roll hall of fame and i was
lucky enough to honor you guys
how has that been you guys feeling good
about that nod that you so what deserve
we were so excited to have you
and i'm so happy we're all very happy
that we're celebrating your birthday
with you drew because we really do adore
you sweetheart we i and we're all really
proud of you we've watched you grow up
you know and um
you've done you you've turned out
beautifully baby you're just fabulous